hello this
wow I can't believe how big this venue
is it's crazy I won't lie him a little
bit nervous but I've got my zelda she
was on my Star Wars belt my transformer
Underpants you don't need to know about
that but I didn't want to start this off
by doing like has anyone seen that
obviously you've seen the simpsons but
the flaming homo where who is it Steve
Tyler gets on stage and shouts hello st.
Louis and I can't do it I can do it too
scared to do it but I say hello everyone
um whoo uh yeah I'm Paul Kinlan I'm an
engineer and developer advocate on the
chrome team and I get to think a lot
about the future of the mobile web we've
been working on a lot of technologies on
the mobile web for a long time now and
kind of i'm in this lucky position where
i can start to think about you know how
all these pieces are coming together
come together and the good thing about
thinking about the future of the mobile
web is that every presentation that you
do you start off with the beginning
there's a big bang moment of like where
but something before the time is like no
one knows about the change and then
after the time everything's changed it's
like a xerneas an epoch you know at that
point where everything that's gone after
changes the world and obviously we're
going to talk about a couple of things
in the future or a couple things I've
happened relatively recently that
changed like the future of mobile
computing but the thing that I think
changed the world would never got any
credit because it never actually got
built was in 1822 when Charles Babbage
built the difference engine and i'm not
sure if you've ever seen this but if you
do it was in the Computer History Museum
when I went it's basically a two-ton
machine which calculates logarithms and
kind of other tabular data now the great
thing was like he designed it in 1822
but the engine SI to the great think
it's terrible thing right he designed it
in 1822 but the engineering wasn't there
to be able to build it at that time and
you never got to build it and the other
problem with it as well was if you
wanted to build another set of kind of
computational functionality you had to
build another to turn machine that would
be designed to solve the problems that
you know you needed to solve it was a
one function machine essentially but
Charles Babbage knew that this was a
limitation and a problem now you'd have
to deal with and so he designed the
analytic he designed the analytical
engine at the point and the analytical
engine he was designed to solve and be
at relatively general
guten platform that would basically take
punch cards and generalized programming
it had lots of the kind of common
program in terms that we knew already
today like if statements and branching
and Lupin and a bunch of other things I
need a Lovelace at the time was one of
the world's first program is if not the
first programmer and they basically
decided to try and build a kid like a
generalized computing platform Henry
Babbage decided to build a prototype and
the prototype didn't actually work quite
right had like rounded errors and off by
one errors and a whole bunch of other
things so he wasn't really the change
that we wanted to see in the world but
the interesting thing is it actually
introduced this idea for me at least a
removable storage in like an SD card for
the time at that point by these punch
cards now you could just enter data in
it wasn't a right only it wasn't a
read/write medium it was a route like a
right only you do it once and then you
push it through and it's red but you
pushed into the Machine and in theory
the calculation would happen when once
it run the program at the end you would
get the kind of the output the thing
that it created like the calculation
that came out on a car and a very formal
like four add a very kind of basic
printer at the time now if you jump
forward another hundred years we're
still using punch cards right we have
these rooms and these machines that the
size of these massive rooms where you
would do suck like design and create a
program take it to the machine you could
post it via like the like the the postal
service you could put it in someone
would put it into the machine it would
go off and you know I say load balance
that's the wrong way of saying it but
your timeshare essentially at that point
at some point in the future you would
get your data back if the program runs
successfully and then you'll be able to
do it the interesting thing for me at
least anyways these machines like they
took away not gonna say that didn't take
away a whole lot of jobs but they
optimize the process of very repetitive
tasks and changed industry at the time
very machine intensive and very kind of
quite interesting but the point is it
was like it was the start of the
computing generation at that point
they've jumped forward again another 20
years we've got rid of the punch cards
and we're at this point where we have
these home computers where you can take
these disks these cassettes put them
into your machine and then start to play
a game and yes it took a long time for
your applications in your games to load
up
the important thing was you could go to
a store a shot by a game take it home
load it up and play it was kind of a
very transformative point in the
computing industry then you move forward
again a little bit further and you know
this idea of floppy disks obviously
there's many different form factors of
floppy disks but the idea behind this
was you could take data right it to a
disk take it from school to your home do
your homework save data transfer
transfer programs and hoping to other
things again on a disk I mean they were
incredibly limited in the terms of like
storage capacity but the fact that you
could transport all the data around it
was again game-changing for a lot of
people now the problem was like if
anyone ever had to install windows 95
you know or office you know using 30
different disks you recognize how long
it took to actually do anything with the
data on those machines which is why when
we came up with the idea obviously the
idea of CDs no CDs invented in the late
80s didn't come into kind of generally
use until the mid-90s but you know again
they transform the way that we actually
you know thought about computing we
could access movies you know
encyclopedias you know windows 95 would
install in an hour you know at that
point like it was quite interesting like
when you think about the next generation
after that again it was a blu rays he
went from six hundred and fifty
megabytes worth of data it's like five
gigabytes or 50 gigabytes worth of data
that you could store the amount of data
that we could transfer on these devices
I was actually amazing but the problem
was at least in the kind of the more
like the more common era that the
installation process and management of
these things was incredibly cumbersome
it was really hard to actually kind of
you'd get an application and then you'd
install it and if you did do it for your
parents you know your parents asking you
to kind of make sure that the machine
worked well and like that's one side of
it but if you're in the enterprise you'd
have to have entire teams built around
this idea of deploying software and the
enterprise you'd have to have user
acceptance testing I in turn obviously
you have to have integration testing but
you have to make sure it works in the
environment is going to run on you jump
forward again a little bit we had this
idea of the web like this is where
things for me start to change
dramatically you enter a single URL and
then you get access to anything that can
access be accessed by the URL we've got
things like hotmail we've got things
like Gmail Google Maps and all those
types of applications
well and then when you thought about
things like the enterprise that was
actually quite interesting as well you
had these massively hosted multi-tenancy
systems that they had no install that
incremental download as you navigated
through the pages and in theory there
were sandbox so one application couldn't
kind of medal with the data that was
held in another application unless
there's like a well-defined API bridge
between the two so for me at least um I
just realized if I stand here I can't it
doesn't reach the thing and I'll stand
here that's fine um but the idea behind
it was I like the web we node we and we
knew that at the time it was far less
capable than the native platforms at the
time didn't have access to the devices
or anything on the actual user's machine
but the delivery model was massively
better it was a lot more efficient a lot
more optimized you basically could build
anything you want and give it to user
just by entering a URL and then you know
I kind of liked it con I kind of like to
think the term is like the original kind
of part of the web where we didn't have
a JAX at the point it was like peak CGI
so you got to the point where you would
you know you'd enter some data into a
form submit it would do some processing
on the server and respond back then we
got this concept Ajax like Ajax could
you could create applications or web two
point O or whatever you want to call it
you could create applications which felt
as rich as a native application on the
desktop but you know they were still
delivered by mobile app like mote the
MOBA delivered by mobile so I delivered
by just entering going to the URL and
that was quite interesting for me
because every single phase in these
computing revolutions some form of
friction was removed it could have been
things like excuse me I could have been
in the amount of data that you could
transfer and put on so you could create
bigger and more interesting applications
or it could have been the mud with the
method and model they've actually
delivering the data to the user that I'd
changed fundamentally and specifically
and I want this is one of the things I
want to try and focus on today is this
idea of like distribution right
distribution was one of the hardest
problems in the software and I'll talk
about this a little bit later on a bit
further but the idea behind distribution
at one point you have to build the
machine yourself and put the code on the
machine yourself to get an application
working to this point in the future
where now we just enter a URL in and we
get to the point where we can just go
and visit the page and actually start
interacting with
the content I think that's incredibly
powerful right like that's a that's a
massive set of step changes since the
dawn of computing i think in 1822 to the
point that we are quite we are right now
but the problem for me is that all these
devices and all these kind of sites and
programs and apps have been designed in
a desktop world they've been designed
for a one point it was 640 by 480
screens at then up to 1024 x 768 and
every time that we kind of got like a
general increase in screen size everyone
like oh my god I have to redesign my
site and it's terrible and it is it's
crazy i kind of think of this is the
like the mobile with akira right it's
like once mobile came along like
everything changed and before that we
are in this kind of nice happy world of
desktop and it kind of in some point in
the near future it's probably gonna look
quite arcane when we go back to how we
used to build software for the at least
in the web and the thing i want to try
and get across as well is that the rate
of change is increasing as well you know
for a long time we just had punch cards
and the ability to actually push data
into a computer that way then we had
disks and then we had CDs and then dvds
and the web came along then and the web
is still there it's a medium we still
use it distribute things but in the
mobile era you know there's a lot more
things coming along we all know about
the app store right but if you look at
the app store as a distribution model
it's great it solves a lot of problems
but there's also a lot of different
things coming along the lines as well
with chat applications as well so if you
look at things I Facebook a do in
another platforms they're giving you
more and more ways on mobile to
distribute software and I'm going to
talk about a little bit more about that
in a bit but this is the point like June
twenty ninth for me is when before that
we had mobile we had whack pages and a
bunch of other things it was kind of a
terrible web on mobile the iphone came
along and it was powered only by mobile
only by mobile only by the web at that
point and they introduced a whole bunch
of new api is for you to be able to
build these great new kind of like web
like applications on their platform and
we'll talk a bit more about how they
change the mind in a minute but this
point before that we didn't have the
full web they sold the phone on the idea
that you could access the full web
desktop web sites the full web on this
small mobile phone device I think that's
an incredible thing
and I also kind of look I mean this I've
made this graph up it's not based on any
real data at the moment at all so I was
like I was like should I caveat this or
no yeah I probably need to tell everyone
it's a fake graph at this point but I
wanted to try and get across the point
is like distribution and the cost of
distribution the difficulty of
distribution of benning decrease in for
a long long time we're at a point in the
world where distribution has never been
easier than it was before but there is
still a number of problems that problems
problems that need to be solved still
and if you look at the native space and
this is a quote from a Gabor and it's
still broadly revell relevant but he
says in a consumer mobile app every step
you make user perform before they get
value out of your application you lose
twenty percent of your users and I that
applies to the web applies a lot of a
lot of other platforms when you look at
the data but the way I you kind of like
to put the clam hang I like the web
right and I don't like native
applications let me have to go through
these stores so I'm a little bit biased
in this sense but when you look at the
kind of the number of steps that you
want to go when you won't install
something like an air horn application
right i mean i've made an air horn web
app as well which I'll encourage you all
to go to in a minute but like the idea
is that you go to the store you find
your application you load the load it up
you find it in the store you click
install you wait for the download except
well accept any permissions if there is
any then you wait for the download and
then and then you might use it once it's
on your home screen and when you look at
the numbers it's like give you you lose
in twenty percent of your kind of
maximum theoretical target set of users
when you start you know when you start
from the beginning well that's actually
pretty bad right because you'll lose in
no twenty percent 20 / so you end up
with less than a third of your overall
users at the end and again this is these
aren't actual figures they suggest an
extrapolation of the actual steps but
when you think about something like the
web again you just have a URL the user
goes to it and then they basically start
using the application at that point and
the comparison for me is quite stark
like we have problems on the web where
we can't make our applications installed
well what we can I'll talk about that
later but the idea is I you know our web
applications and our websites they're
not like traditional native applications
they don't feel like they're supposed to
be native but the thing is if you want
user to use your experience you give
them
URL you still lose some users out of
your maximum theoretical target but
you'll have a lot more users at the end
and when you think about it as a graph I
think it's quite interesting right you
can see the difference I can know
there's a lot of worst-case scenarios as
well in terms of native applications and
I'm railing on native applications a
little bit at the moment but the thing
that I have the thing I want a question
and I question for everyone else is that
native platforms know that there is a
distribution problem if you're the App
Store give the Android Marketplace
Android Play Store oh my god car it's
cold yeah you know that this is a
problem and you want to optimize that
for every single user right you want to
make sure uses a download in your
applications so the question isn't
really what happens when native is
wouldn't solve this because if you look
at what Android is doing their they're
actually trying to solve this right now
and I think this is interesting because
Android instant apps they're in theory a
threat to the web at some point because
you go to URL and if that if the the
site owner wants you to download an app
they can just say download the app
instead like I think the web has got
tremendous advantage because we have the
ability to progressively render the
experience whereas with these type of
experience you have to download the
entire package before you start to use
it and I think there's a problem but
like it's interesting right because
native applications are trying to take
all the best bits from the web and what
we're going to talk about today is like
how we can take on the web all the best
bits from native and kind of like
there's going to be a crossover at some
point where it doesn't probably really
matter what you decide to build it in
it's just everything's going to be
accessible via the web so web
development itself might change but this
work this is where it gets right as I
give you a developer and what you choose
to deploy on the thing that you end up
competing on is engagement right it's
like these steps like once users open
the application to do in and perform in
the task is like it's all user
experience at that point and I'm not
going to talk about user experience
today because I'm I'm not user
experience person and all that a P is so
I think that's interesting right as a
potential future for the web where the
web is going I don't quite know at the
moment I think there are potentially a
lot of threats out there but the one
thing I do you want to talk about
briefly is like the the idea with where
the web is at the moment in terms of
users right like we know all know about
kind of the eight second piece of data
is like the average web site takes at
least eight seconds to load or
before anything is on the screen but we
know that forty percent of users in you
abandoned a website if it takes more
than three seconds to load we have
problems with our kind of ecosystem and
industry where we're kind of happy with
a slow experience and I think this is
important especially on mobile because
and I'm going to talk about India in a
minute but I want to kind of concentrate
on some of the US side of things where
the number of u.s. households that are
actually just cellular only it's about
twenty percent of households apparently
and I've got some data which i haven't
actually put the link on for which I'll
share later but that's doubled since
2013 and it's going to keep increasing
and increasing more and more people are
going to go mobile and you think great
because everyone's gonna be on 4G well
I'm in the US at the moment I'm on Roman
it's 2g only for me at the moment
unfortunately a lot of people don't have
great connections even if they're going
to go mobile only when you think about
the bigger picture the context of like
the rest of the world like sixty percent
of the rest of the world who are mobile
connected they're only on 2g so kind of
thinking about how to optimize
performance and the way we go like for
performance at least it's going to be
like the next big thing that we're going
to do now yes they technology is
improving but even with the kind of
predictions that they got now it's like
2020 it's looking to have twenty percent
of people on a2g based connection and
but this is important for me because
I've been out to India and Indonesia and
you know a lot of places recently and
I've spoken to a lot of users and a lot
of developers about what they need to
target and how they're trying to build
software on the web it's kind of
interesting because like America and
Europe and the UK they're kind of we've
got the web and we've got computing at
this point I knew enough everyone has
got a computer and if you look at the
current estimates i think it's about 286
million people in the US of God I've got
a mobile internet connection ah india is
need nearly it's not quite double its
like 480 million people have got mobile
like mobile connectivity at the moment
china is like more combined than anyone
else and like it's 750 million people
have got like a mobile Internet
connectivity and I think that's
incredible really like China's hmm what
do I say out China it's it's often its
own little place the web in China is
very different to the web that we know
but if you go to India the web that they
experience in India is very much like
the web that we experience at least but
for me like like their big market right
but the grow
earth is still from 2014 2 2015 like
there wasn't one hundred million people
in India alone join the web mobile in
particular because everyone is like
mobile first right there for some
people's first computing devices or
mobile devices that's 10 * to go to
China more than a hundred times the
potential growth in any of the other
countries that we've got and the way I
look at it is like a third of the u.s.
basically come online just in India
alone for me it's like in the UK we have
like 60 70 million people like the size
of the UK every single year is coming
online in india I think that's crazy
because I they're either going to choose
this point where they want applications
or they want like web like web
experiences and the growth in the
ecosystem is absolutely huge like said
there's sixty-five percent of India's
overall ecosystem is still not online
yet so there's still potential huge
potentials for growth now the
interesting thing about them is like
when you compare things like this is the
6p at the time are three gig around 120
gigabytes of storage like the one of the
most popular devices launched last year
was the samsung j1 it's like four
gigabyte of storage and 512 megabytes of
RAM this kind of these types of like
poor devices to some extent you look at
things like the Moto G as well like
these constrain devices if once you've
done your basic install of a couple of
applications you can't update them
anymore you can't download any more
applications like the device constraints
that a lot of people have in the world
materially impact the way that they can
use native experiences and this is why i
think the web is actually kind of really
good for a lot of people is because like
it's not really like a you when you go
off and download and install stuff you
just kind of passively consume the
experience as you go through and yes
will cache data and will store it online
sorry offline on the user's device but
you don't have to worry about these
massive downloads and I think the web
has got an interest in value proposition
but it's not just about things like
devices as well you know we said that
before obviously forty percent of people
drop off a site if it takes more than
three seconds to load there are a lot of
other pieces of data that suggests that
if a one-second delay is a you know
eleven percent for your page views you
know sixteen percent decrease in
customer satisfaction but like we know
this but like the thing for me is when
you think about the data like when
you're in the UK for instance you'll use
Wi-Fi a lot of times like when you go to
India and a lot of other places you know
people are just on cellular
on cellular pretty much all the time a
cellular data costs a lot of money right
when you think about it like if you do
some basic calculations and India's
minimum wage varies across the country
and the type of job that you're on but
roughly 17 hours will like a minimum
work so minimum wage were so minimum
wage work will get you 500 megabytes
worth of data and I think that's
incredibly because people are buying
these devices and they get value out of
using the applications and the websites
on them as well but when you think about
the size of the web and like what we're
doing to build sites I think that's
quite interesting because we have at
this point you know one hour's worth of
Indian minimum work minimum work minimum
wage work is a roughly 15 page loads
right and if you think about the number
of pages that you potentially visit
today on your mobile device like that's
pretty crazy right it's relatively
constrained what people can do so I do
want to highlight and emphasize the fact
that performance is everything whether
you're in the US whether you're in the
UK or whether you're kind of targeting
and answering emerging markets but like
the next billion users as we tend to
call it and it's not just kind of
download size it also kind of covers you
know because the devices can be
relatively constrained user interactions
scroll in you know the whole kind of
performance piece and we're not doing a
very good job on the web industry as a
whole are actually catering for there is
one other area that I want to briefly
talk about and if this a whole idea I've
been trying to think about the rise of
the meta platforms and what this is is
we have iOS we have Android as the two
mobile platforms you know desktop that's
fine you can build applications and
deploy them on them we know that that's
cool but the web sits across everything
right the web is across all these
different platforms and we can deploy to
it and it's great because that means
everyone can access that and this is
like the traditional view that we all
have of the meta platforms the web is
the metal platform but when you look at
mobile in particular you start to see
things like messaging applications you
know Facebook line kakow you know we
chat there's whole bunches of messaging
applications that I've got hundreds of
millions if not billions of users like
Facebook with billions of a daily active
you or billions a billion daily active
users or whatever that the late starts
were like use a time and use your
attention is in these applications like
pretty much all the time and they're all
starting to kind of scope our right so
they're sitting there going we
want to own the content experience we
want to own the application experience
we have all these users we can do a lot
of things with them and if you look at
just the pure content side we've got you
know iOS Apple news I don't think it's
particularly successful we've got things
like instant articles Facebook of
pushing that like crazy check out your
reach out reach out again like when you
when you think about China's sometimes
you can go and look at reach out and the
entire web is inside we chat and people
to build and experiences in there but
the thing that people are doing and the
reason why people are actually or say
people these companies are actually
talking about these experiences in these
platforms is because performance is the
key selling point like if it's that
eight second page load and you see in
all the advertising for these platforms
is it takes eight seconds to load the
average web page on mobile that is a
terrible experience we can load it in
100 milliseconds that's what all these
platforms are selling I think it's a
little bit more kind of complex than
that I think you know if you're I mean
Google properties it's as well right but
like Facebook or review any of these
other platforms if you want to keep the
person or the user inside your platform
because you already have the use of
tension sends them outside into this
kind of open wide world over the web
suppose you probably don't want them to
do that so you want to kind of think
about how you can keep the content and
those experiences for as long as
possible on your platform and then when
you look at the web we don't have like
we don't have an extra kind of thing
that focuses just purely on performance
can I can't like kind of combat those
are the kind of platforms now I don't
want to kind of sound like it's a
marketing thing there is like kind of
how to talk about this is an interesting
one is like Google has made this project
or amp and amp is quite interesting
because it their theory is it's an open
source project and it just so happens
that Google implement amp inside the
news part of search but the idea is like
Twitter use this as well but like it's a
relatively constrained platform of known
performance problems that solved and got
out the way using custom elements and a
whole bunch of other things which will
allow you to build a fast experience the
goal of amp is to build fast experiences
and they do that by restricting and
constraining the platform about what you
can deploy as one option there's there's
a lot of other kind of options out there
but you know even as a normal developer
you shouldn't have to worry about these
technologies you should just be focusing
on the idea of performance especially in
the content space and now if you look at
these
the platform's again like Facebook line
you know the web is the next one as well
but like the wii they all want to be
like the next browser right if you think
about these applications sits
specifically the messaging applications
they want you in the experience all the
time and kind of consuming those
services now I think that's interesting
because when you look at the API space
that they're offering they're starting
to introduce things like messenger BOTS
because you know it's you know
lightweight interactions of
communicating with the service I think
it's incredibly powerful but when you
look at the way that they're building
these things they can't go off and
deploy brand new applications they can't
go and deploy brand new applications out
you know by a native code they use in
kind of all the web technologies around
to support their kind of platforms
because you know on iOS and Android you
can update JavaScript code you can
update kind of web based code
dynamically as you want whenever you
want and not have to go through any
approvals and reviews but the
interesting thing is that because you
own the webview and you're using that
experience you can start to introduce
new api's which are available developers
so a lot of the platforms are thinking
about identity like integrated identity
integrated payments a lot of other
integrated API is that in some cases
might not make sense on the web but make
a lot of sense to users they've got a
web which is not really the web and I
don't know whether that is a good thing
or a bad thing but the point is again
the reach and distribution is phenomenal
phenomenal but I can't say the word
terrible but that is kind of I talked
about the history I talked about the
kind of the current way of the world I
think at the moment so what is the
future I mean this the whole point of
this talk the future of the mobile web
well I come up with a rel if you really
rough idea I think it is it's like this
whole idea of gay I bought an ipad pro
just so I could draw graphics and this
is the only graphic that I can actually
do with it it's terrible in it like
everyone like my friend Paul Lewis I he
does these beautiful graphics and he's
got like animated characters in and
stuff and I just come up with these
stupid drawings anyway that the idea
about the web right and if you look at
the browser vendors and what they're
trying to do they have a rough plan of
like a plan of attack and like it's in
kind of four areas the first is to try
and match native on features not
directly on features like you don't like
one so you don't have us
on the web we're going to have us be on
the web but it's kind of of the web
following the same security model it's
not just blind access to all these api's
but we want to make sure that there is
no reason why someone would deploy to
native over the web because for a long
time that is what it was is like the web
can't do X that's why I need to have an
eighth of application so we want to make
sure that the web platform is capable we
want to focus on performance and then we
want to also increase engagement and I'm
going to talk briefly about progressive
web apps in the idea of increasing
engagement but the first thing is like
this is not anything that you can do
really unless you're a browser vendor is
that everyone needs to get there you
know get their mess together right is
that we've spent a long time building
different features and different
capabilities and it's fine right in that
browsers where you might introduce one
big API like we're Bluetooth right we're
bluetooth is in chrome as an experiment
at this point it's in chrome but you
know it's in in chrome and you can
choose to build on the web or not but
when you get to something like flexbox
which is supposed to be supported across
every single browser you have to deal
with the fact that there's two different
versions are there that there's UC
browser version of it which is renders
differently to everything else like
there's just lots of little errors in
between them a lots of different
implementation issues it's just a
massive nightmare to deploy just basic
web applications across the entirety of
the web and there's a lot of browser
vendors like Microsoft if you speak to
rick buyers from the chrome team he's
got this predictable like predictability
plan the idea behind predictability is
make it easier for developers to build
great websites and applications so
browser vendors need to do this and
you're going to see more and more kind
of things coming through of just
consistency and fixing things on the
idea imagine native again this is
another I didn't caveat this graph this
is a completely made of graph again but
this point I wanted to get across was
when I phone launched it was web only
right they introduced a huge amount of
AP eyes which were mobile-centric app
cache local storage media queries huge
amounts of different api's which made
sense for the mobile web versus just the
pure desktop where there's a lot of
vision and forethought that went into
making a good mobile web experience but
they kind of realized that developer
didn't really want to deploy native
applications on the web at this point
they wanted native experiences and they
wanted a way to distribute it and but we
know the story right the minute that
Apple introduced like their platform and
the app
store boom right it just everything
changed completely right it's like the
web just did not keep up you got more
access to api's sensors huge amounts of
different application AP is just on the
native platforms it took a long time
right I blame Android for this as well
to some extent is like you know Android
had a really crappy browser for like the
android browser for such a long time
which never got many updates at all we
just stagnated for a long time it wasn't
until like the industry as a whole
started to get together and say we just
need to improve we need to offer more
experiences to users like what are their
problems that they have and we'll cover
them in a minute but there are a lot of
different API is that are available on
the web right i mean when you look about
when you look at that i say when you
look at the number of mobile-centric
api's that came around I'll list some of
them now you got things I geolocation
right its user permission required right
you can't give access to anyone's
location just whenever you want it's a
https only now in chrome and firefox at
least you know we've got things like the
camera right where it works across hey
again it's you need a user gesture to
access the camera and you can access it
in line inside your application and it
falls back to iOS but you can use the
native camera at that point we get
things like the microphone right you can
record audio again in line because we've
got access to the microphone and the
camera and I'll bunch of other things
but again it's locked behind the whole
set of permissions HTTPS only but again
if you're an iOS you can still use the
native application to record data and
put it into your application we have
things I battery status so you can
understand i don't really this api makes
no sense like I don't send an xml
httprequest when it's on five percent
battery maybe I don't know but the idea
is that you know you you've got this
side this access to hardware more
information about the device that we
never had before we got permissions so
you can offer extreme lined experiences
you can give the user confidence that
they can disable all the permissions
that they're granted if they've given
you geolocation for instance and they
don't want to give it to you anymore
they don't have to go through crawling
through all the chrome menus to go and
get it you've just access it through the
permissions API you can understand the
network information so you as the user
on cellular connection are they on a
Wi-Fi connection you can also get the
maximum theoretical speed of the
connection as well and this this came
from when we were in India and a lot of
Indian developers were saying if we
understand the maximum theoretical
connection
on speed we can optimize the user
experience I've not seen anyone actually
use it just yet but the data is there
and you're able to use it to build
experiences and this is an incredibly
boring piece right autofill but by
implementing the correct tags and meta
data on your input fields you can vastly
improve the performance of your your
your forms like the web is mostly about
forms right you're entering data trying
to complete the purchase and everyone
hates typing on the keyboard we can
solve that you know across multiple
browsers now just by providing the
correct metadata inside the page but
when you think about what you can do to
enter data into a form like obviously
everyone normally has to sign in and
sign up to a service and then login time
time again the idea behind the
credential management API is like well
you can synchronize like you the user
logs in you can synchronize that
credentials across all the devices that
they're connected to so that when they
go from machine to machine or come back
again you lay just press one button in
their log straight in because the
underlying operating system chrome in
this case or the different browsers
because they go okay it's great I can do
hope and just I know the users logged in
I'll log them back in and then if you
follow on from the credential management
side of things you've got things like
the payments API you probably all know
about Apple pay and it's a great
introduction to the web the fact that
you can streamline the payment
experience no one likes entering data
into forms an Apple pay is really smooth
experience on mobile but there is and
also an open version of that the payment
request API which was just released in
chrome and their number of the browser
vendors are also working on it Microsoft
working on it as well now the idea
behind this is that you can integrate
with like platform specific payment
providers like Android pay in this case
that's a bit of advertisements posen it
android pay but if you're on samsung
maybe you could integrate into a samsung
thing well or whatever it's down to the
application though the operating system
to provide that resolution of services
but it can also integrate into your
existing check out flows if you've got
stripe you can provide all the data
straight through to stripe just by one
tap on the screen from the user and the
really interesting thing is I give
you've already got the credit card
information you probably don't want this
API but if you're trying to onboard a
user through a guest checkout experience
like you can combine that with the
credential management API to
automatically create user account which
is then the synchronize across a whole
bunch of devices I think it's quite
powerful there's a lot of things to go
on in this space and I'm sorry to
talking really fast
sorry we have pushed the idea of push
notifications it's one of the biggest
features that people requested for why
they were building for native you know
the idea that you can send a
notification to a user about an
important action on the page even when
the browser is closed native
applications can do this for a while for
a long time now the great thing is again
it's gated on a user permission we just
don't get free access to send
notifications willy-nilly we can just
new send it straight through I send it
straight through you have to like once
they have to accept it and then we can
send the permissions we have this idea
of God sorry offline support as well you
know we obviously we've got things like
app cache service worker is I'm going to
talk about service work a bit more it's
a major API that's come through that
allows you to have more fine-grained
control over the offline experiences you
know install ability if you use their
application manifest you can make sure
like you could use a web developer can
control how your website your web
application looks and feels when the
user chooses to install it on the users
on the user's home page now on the
user's home screen I think that's
incredibly important right like rather
than just kind of bookmark a page at the
home screen you can just say well this
demo the demo is working great the demo
didn't look like he was working but you
can add it to the home screen and it
launches and you know you get this kind
of full screen application like
experience I think that's incredibly
powerful when you think about the future
of the web especially when you trying to
build more application like experiences
on the web now we get into the more
experimental place like the browser
vendors want to make sure that you can
have access to pretty much everything
you know the user wants to have access
again all gated by user permissions it's
not just kind of blind discover all the
devices around me and connect them you
have to be very specific but you can you
know just connect to a Bluetooth device
start controlling it this is Spiros bb-8
the top corner there that just
JavaScript commands and being senator or
commands being sent over JavaScript to
the device then there's things like the
generic sensor API which is not in
chrome just yet but if you speak to some
of the people at Intel that they're
doing is a lot of work on this and you
sent me the demo for it yesterday but
the idea is that you know you get
wrought like we used to build high level
API is to get access to all these senses
but the idea is that you get a low level
set of primitives to access and connect
to any set of sensors and then you can
build higher level abstractions on that
so you don't have to wait for the
platform to keep you know you
vendors to keep kind of connected like
updating their platforms updating their
browser just add new hardware in now
things like magnetometer and
accelerometer those type of things but
then you can create fused sensors so you
can create a compass off combining the
magnetometer and the accelerometer quite
powerful especially if you want hardware
access web USB by the important thing to
say about web USB is like it's not just
like open to every single type of device
that you want to connect to you can't
connect to the users web USB camera the
hardware provider has to make the
website that can access the device and
it has to be encoded on the device of
the Europe it's really complex but the
idea is that like you can't just access
anything that you want if you wanted to
have some hardware you as though as the
hardware developer would control the
website that only has access to that
piece of hardware it's relatively
complex and they want a lot more
feedback on this place something that's
very close to my heart because I was
working on web intents for a long time
is native sharing the idea is that you
can be on a web page share out to a
native application it's really hard to
do at the moment especially on other
platforms but that's not the only thing
right like that's good that you can
share to a native app but what about
native application when you do a share
action like you want your web
application if your Twitter and you're
only on the web you want your website to
be in that list of things that you can
share too from native and then the ship
navigated a share an API is pretty
powerful right because you can say i
want to share to a native application i
want my web application to be shared to
another web application i want my web
application to being the list of things
that native application would share too
i think it's incredibly powerful and
then there's things like web PR right
like web PR and this is that was ages
ago as 3g and 3gs is brilliant right but
the idea behind web PR is you know it's
it's vr on the web right but the thing
that's interesting for me is that this
is coming out and being developed to
kind of come out when all the other
mobile platforms are ready for VR right
it's not like we're going to have to
wait one maybe two years before we have
a generalized web capable VR system it's
nearly ready and it's at that point of
where you know when native gets it the
web gets it at the same time but the web
will be able to do so much more because
we can provide web like experiences you
go to a website and you can flick on VR
mode if you want to give the user wanted
it that way I don't know how it's just
successful it's going to be it might not
be that successful because you need a
big piece of hardware on your face to
actually sort this thing out but it's
kind of interesting
but the interesting thing for me at
least is that you know as you can see
the web has been catching up right like
we've been getting more and more and
more kind of closer to the native
experiences we technically still got a
real long way to go but that's the
intent of some of their kind of the
platform developers but the question is
and everyone says like that's just a
list of API is right it's not a real
strategy and you're right and also they
don't work in other browsers right but
like that every browser vendor know is
that they can ship these features but
like you get the big features which you
have to choose to implement or not but
then you have this whole idea of the
predictability making it easy for
developers to actually build experiences
that work cross-platform quite easily
and then progressively enhance as you go
on I'm not going to concentrate too much
on performance I'm going to be really
fast through it but the idea behind
performance is there's anyone heard of
rail 12 you've all heard a rail now but
the idea behind rail at least it's a
very user centric model for thinking of
performance the idea here is that you
know you should respond to user gestures
within 100 milliseconds animations you
know 60 frames second you shouldn't do
anything that blocks the renderer from
actually maintaining 16 millisecond
frames idle time is interesting right
because it's really hard to think about
idle time but you know a lot of people
put in work which takes a long time to
do takes more than 50 milliseconds and
if the user clicks a button and then the
user interface doesn't respond because
it's doing some work or the other the
browser can't respond in time then it
feels like feels lucky so the idea is I
you know make sure you can chunk your
work up and the complex computation
either into something like a web worker
or in 250 milliseconds and then focus on
and say a load time of one second it's
not really a full load time of one
second it's that's incredibly hard to
achieve but the idea is that for the
user something is visible and something
is interactable within one second the
application doesn't have to be
completely loaded and it encourage you
to look at Paul Lewis's work on
progressive rendering and especially
bootstrapping I know a lot of developers
use frameworks and we see a lot of
applications where you know they'll pull
the framework in and it'll take a long
time for the framework to boot up and
then you know it's like maybe it's a lot
of time just in JavaScript kind of
initializing there the framework system
and then loading up the rest of the page
and data binding before anything is
visible on the page and there's nothing
wrong with using frameworks so like it
makes everyone deliver more effective
software more quickly
with less bugs but you have to think
more tactically about how you deploy
your applications at that point and you
know like I can talk about API for a
long time there are a couple of
different API is that come into the web
which is just focused on making more
helping you make more perform
applications intersection observer like
when a Dom element comes into the screen
you'll get notification that's great and
things like request idle call back if
you want to chunk your work in 250
milliseconds request idle callback will
say hey we think there's a 50
millisecond break that you can you can
actually start to execute some stuff in
and I know a number of a bigger
companies start to use the API at the
moment so increasing engagement right
that's probably the biggest piece that
we need we've got a whole set of api's
that's great and then we want to focus
on performance but the biggest bit is
just about providing good experiences to
users and where we ask developers you
know what do you want at this was like
in 2013 at the point like what you want
to be able to build a compelling next
general or not you know compelling a
generation experience but build a
compelling experience that would mean
that you don't have to go to native and
the order that everything came back was
access install ability to the home
screen push notifications and then good
offline support there are a couple of
other things that came back off the back
but it's it's actually relatively hard
like those api's exist now and we can
tell developers about it but like it's
really quite hard to think about how you
package them all up into a a framework
or at least a way of thinking about how
you combine them all together so we
thought this idea called progressive web
applications I'm going to talk briefly
about it at the moment but the start of
it was in June of 2015 Alex Alex Russell
and Francis Berryman and they started
thinking about how you can deliver like
these applications these new types of
applications with all these new api's
and the idea was like you don't want to
just offer an install button and make it
like a nav app like straight away
because the user might not be engaged
but if the user is engaged the more they
use the experience the more app like it
becomes so like if you use the site and
you go run navigate around the site at
some point it's like hey this you
probably want this on your home screen
do you want to install it doesn't do it
straight away it does it after maybe
three visits to the side or it's like
hey you're really engaged we do push
notifications do you want push
notifications so rather than trying to
get access to all these features
straight away the more the user use the
site the more progressively it would be
coming
stalled on the device now the idea is
like progressive is a really overloaded
term we encourage progressive
enhancement as well because we know the
api's on available on all platforms but
they are kind of like you can build
great web applications just by changing
the way you think about building
experiences but like the big question
that everyone has is what makes a
progressive web app and it was only last
week but Alex actually actually posted
this because we get the question quite a
lot because it's about to be nebulous
right it's like what is web 2.0 or what
is Ajax like Ajax was xmlhttprequest and
XML Jason and a bunch of a synchronicity
and a bunch of other API is right it
wasn't Ajax wasn't an ajax aight wasn't
just about the api is it was about the
way you thought about building these
experiences and he came up with this
list and its really hit I think it's
really interesting because it's really
boring he originates progressive web app
originates from a secure origin has to
be on HTTPS loads while offline even if
it's just a basic kind of oh sorry you
can't access the Guardian calm at the
moment and it references a web app
manifest and the web app manifest I'm
not going to talk about cuz I don't have
a huge amount of time but that describes
how your application should appear on
the user's device like what should the
bookmark be watch it alone should launch
full screen and those types of things
it's relatively simple just it's a
manifest file but when you go a little
bit further it's actually just about
making sure your sites are responsive
you know there they work across all
different device formats whether form
factors instant right that we think we
can use service work on a bunch of other
technologies to deliver near-instant
load in pages right first load still
might take a little while but every
subsequent load if you're in control the
network you can make it instant a load
like 20 30 milliseconds to have an
experience on the page it's reliable
even in the presence of like
intermittent data connectivity like if
you're browsing through a page you
shouldn't just go are you don't have
internet connectivity you can't go and
view the next page like we should be
able to be resilient to that and it
should be smooth you know performance
and engage in right like the idea is
that if you want to happen on the home
screen or you want to have it push
notifications you should be able to do
those types of things but there is one
core API that controls all this and it's
called the service worker and I'm not
going to go through too much of the
service worker but the idea behind
service work and I encourage you all to
look at this is the idea is it
introduces an app like life cycle to
website right every single say what I
say a site
I mean like all the pages that are
contained inside that site traditionally
web pages they have their own life cycle
they have like all the different life
events like dumb content loaded unloaded
and a bunch of other things as well but
that's just for the single page load
that the serviceworker itself kind of
lives outside of the page and outside
the site will control everything in the
site and it can do a lot of things like
its goal is to be in situ get installed
and be activated but once it's activated
its goal is to be asleep and then only
respond to system level events and
that's really interesting when you think
about system level events is because
what type of system level events are
there well there's things like the fetch
API you in control the network any
network request that comes from your
website you can decide what to do with
it you push events notifications
notifications can live on your browser
on your device for 10 20 minutes two
days two weeks you don't want your web
page open for the entire time that that
notification is visible so like that's
what happens is the notification gets
raised and then your service worker goes
to sleep and only comes back on when the
notification is clicked the idea behind
it is like it acted for a bit then it
goes back to idle at that point and it's
quite simple I say it's quite simple to
implement I'm really massively
generalizing at the moment but the idea
behind it is that you you basically
check to see if there's a service worker
you don't need a service worker to build
a web app but if you do you can enhance
it quite well and then you register a
small javascript file the serviceworker
file and then it starts through its
application lifecycle it's quite I'd say
it's quite simple like you'll remember
like this this is asynchronous right so
you can still use your entire site in
your page but as you're using it and
kind of navigate in between all the
pages the service workers sitting there
going okay I'll install that's like the
traditional application install process
what do I need to be installed in some
cases nothing so that's fine and saw the
cases I need to make sure I download all
the assets that I need for my
application and once I was assets
downloaded you store them in the cache
and then it's activated and then it
comes back out and everything's ready
the way I like to think about it is this
a traditional model of the web right
you're enter URL go to the server vendor
something sends it back and it renders
it inside the page the service workers
interesting because it sits in between
the browser and the network at this
point so the request will come through
the service worker and then you decide
what to do take a client-side proxy at
this point this is it's a lot of code in
this slide and real sorry for this but
fetch event is the thing that gets fired
whenever there's a network like a
network request generated from your web
page and you decide what to do respond
from the cache go out to the network and
then push it back in lots of different
things but the thing is and the biggest
point is that the serviceworker put you
in direct control of how the offline
experience works and you can even do
things like with analytics where this is
our analytics plugin where analytics
doesn't work offline but if you want to
make sure you have offline analytics you
can just queue up all the results when
you come back online you send them back
up through the google analytics but
because you're in control you also get
to do whatever pattern that you want for
offline support so you can support
things like Network first where you will
always go to the network and then cash
the results as they come in and then if
you're offline return the things from
the cash instead it can work you can do
the incremental cash as you know you
always serve from the cash but as you go
around the site everything is cached as
you go you can do stale whilst we
validate and this this is what i use my
blog is that everything is always
returned from the cash but at the same
time i always connect to the network and
then update the cache so the next time
that you go to it you've got there
revalidated and updated content but
because again you're in control you can
do whatever you want and you can follow
any application programming model that
you want as well so we have this thing
called the application shell if you're
not if you've been building native
applications is but it's probably very
familiar is you have all the content in
the assets and the structure of your
application separate from the content
and you kind of cash all that and make
sure that's like download and inns in
the install phase and then you kind of
cash separately all the content as the
user navigator on the site so i like to
think like this is the the overall
progressive web experience it's like the
biggest thing for me is that we want to
focus on reliability if something is
installed at the home screen like it
shouldn't use i shouldn't click on it
and it shouldn't like give you the
dinosaur it should click on it and then
at least the user gets an experience but
one of the biggest things for me but
then obviously we want to make things
fast because you're in control the
network you can be a lot more effective
on that side of things but obviously you
want to focus on the user the user side
performance as well and then you
obviously you get things like engagement
as well like if you wanted to be on the
home screen or you want push
notifications you get that package and
as a package you can start to think
about building these relatively
compelling experiences so for me like
service worker is to progressive web art
of service workers that makes sense
anyway like service workers are to
progressive web apps as xmlhttprequest
was to ajax it's a technology in a
broader suite of technologies that when
you think about building these
next-generation experiences you can
start to apply them together like things
like the app shell like people are
starting to used app shell as a concept
just because like they're thinking about
the progressive web app model not that
they're necessarily using service worker
and I think that's itself is quite
powerful so that's the future as in kind
of the near future and this is my
hypothetical one I got lots of
hypothetical things right but I do like
to think of like more far like far
future things about where the web is
going to go and I think what's going to
happen in the near future is that we're
going to start to see web experiences
that like our of the web host it on the
web ephemeral as in like you can use it
super lightweight experience when you
stop using it it doesn't think of any
more resources on your device but you're
never going to see a browser you'll
still be web content but you want to
your browser and I did this post and I
forgot to put the URL and properly but
the headless web is some of my
thinking's around this and the idea
behind it is that there's different
models for where the browser interaction
happens is like you have the browser on
the device it's fine then you have all
these connected things around you where
the browser is starting to push out on
to things like watches for instance and
then there's kind of other fart like
further like further kind of held
devices as well it's a relatively
nebulous post I'll be honest but I do I
want to show you some things where I
think it makes a little bit more sense
so this is the first bit is like we kind
of starting to slightly take the browser
outside of its kind of local confines
and this is you know the theory is you
could build a podcast app or whatever it
is and then it will be automatically
hooked up to any kind of operating
system-level functionality which could
be expressed in this case via connection
connectivity to your Android watch who
has an android watch three people yes
but it could be connected to all these
devices and because you can control it
from your watch like the web page is
still running on your phone technically
it's behind the scenes but you might
never for a long time actually have to
interact with it and then it's going to
be more and more these kind of
experiences kind of popping up in a
period then we have things like the
physical web where you IOT devices you
know parking meters actually a source in
parking meters outside earlier on which
is to be good for they can broadcast the
URL so rather than having to download an
application and install it well you just
kind of say oh this is the thing that's
in front of me I'll click and open the
web page and then I'll start interacting
with it and this is what's happening
here but again this is still inside the
browser in theory but you get to the
point of like the the system level
discovery services for beacons can
provide a lot more kind of context and a
lot more actions if you can describe in
schema.org or some of the metadata the
actions that can take place on your page
purchase this movie ticket then that
could be surfaced up in many different
places especially inside these neat
inside the application picker that we
saw at the start of this like you can
get to the point where it's all powered
by the web the payment is taken by the
web but it's done by this very
lightweight interaction that lives
inside another application and then you
get things like notifications the
Guardian based in this is in New York
they divert other but they developed a
really nice notification demo it's a
little mini application that only lives
for the entirety of the time that you
interact with the notification you
launch like you launch the experience to
get notified about some interesting news
it's send you it and then you go through
and answer these questions it gives you
all the context all the information that
you need and then at the end it says do
you want to go visit the page and yeah
yeah okay I'll come visit the page but
by itself it's a really nice lightweight
headless application and then when you
think about these things on the device
what happens when it's on the server
well this is what you know you're
probably all know phantom j/s and
integrated into your continuous
integration tests chrome is now doing
headless chrome and starting to build
this and this is where it gets quite
interesting because once you think about
the types of things you can do on the
server like you can start to think about
different types of applications that you
can build out as well which we don't
even think about right now one of them
and this isn't with headless chrome but
it's a headless version of WebKit if
something like PageSpeed insights right
it goes off downloads a page and then
does deep inspection of all the
JavaScript and all
network requests and everything that was
generated by the page which you wouldn't
get just by passing the page normally
through a normal kind of web page passer
we get to this bit where the web browser
on a server goes off fetches the data
does analytics and information like
analysis on it and then presents that a
relatively nice report and then there's
another one that we've worked on as well
called lighthouse and if you speak to
Paul Lewis or ideas man you're Paul
Irish they're actually working on this
project right now and the idea is that
you can take you take things like
headless chrome integrate it into your
continuous integration environment and
run any set of tests that you want to
try and run on them and again because
you can run these things on the server
you can do huge amount of things off the
back of that so I do want to say like
for me it's I know I've talked about in
the mobile web it's not just about
mobile it is a lot about like the web as
a whole new desktop phones obviously for
mobile and any other kind of experiences
that we're going to get I do think our
platform has become a lot more capable
over the roast with over the recent
years and although the browser vendors
are all catching up and we're all
starting to kind of get a level playing
field so we can deliver compelling
experiences and it's a great matter
platform but as a whole ecosystem we
really do have to start focus on how we
build these next-generation experiences
we need to concentrate on performance we
need to concentrate on user experience
and making sure if we want the
application is kind of this idea of a
progressive web application where if the
user wants to have it installed they can
have these applications installed so
that's me I'm done I'm a little bit over
thank you very much